So here's a general way of
writing these averagers.
So what we need,
is there's a set of states.
And we're going to need to define
the value at those states.
And there's a second set of states.
What I was calling the anchor
points here, or the basis set.
>> Mm-hm.
I love basis sets.
>> To define the value of sum state s,
we need to know
what the convex combination of
the basis values we're going to take.
So we need to have specified
what the basis set is.
It's going to be, part of our function
approximator's going to get to pick
the value at those basis points.
And we have to pre-define the averaging
weight, the convex combination weight,
between any given state that we want
to do an approximation, and any given
basis point, any anchor point that we
want to adopt some of its value for.
So, these are the parameters that
the function approximator gets to alter.
These are all predefined.
Things that define how the value
of other states are going to
be defined in terms of these parameters.
So it looks a lot like the linear case,
right?
Except, it's not.
>> Well, in particular,
aren't you're missing something?
I mean, I was going to say it looks
just like the linear case, but
there's nothing in there that forces
it to be a convex combination,
the way you've written it.
>> Right.
So that goes without saying,
but I should probably say it.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> These particular weights that
we're defining, need to make it so
that the value of any state, is a convex
combination of these parameters.
So I wrote that in math, too.
So for all states and
basis points, or anchor points,
the weight between them is not negative,
and they sum up to 1.
>> Okay.
>> This let's us express things,
like these kind of linear interpolation
that we mentioned before.
And in fact,
even these kinds of smoothed, or
maybe even kernalized
representations work as well.
As long as at any point where
you need to make a prediction,
there is a set of these weights w,
that define how we're going to define
the value at that point, in terms of
the value of the set of anchor points.
>> Sounds good to me.